i
[Música]
a
gruesa se enfrenta a una segunda ola de
coronavirus y aquí en moscú la principal
preocupación es la posibilidad de un
nuevo confinamiento sobre todo por los
efectos económicos que podría tener
especialmente sobre el consumo según los
últimos datos el consumo en el sector
servicios ha caído en torno a un 14% lo
cual ha provocado disminución en el
nivel de ingresos de hasta el 18 por
ciento en algunos sectores y eso sin
confinamiento también preocupa la
debilidad del rublo respecto al dólar y
el euro hay que recordar que en las
últimas semanas la moneda rusa ha
alcanzado mínimos históricos respecto a
los últimos 4 o 5 años y eso tiene
importantes efectos en la cesta de la
compra puesto que encarece algunos
productos como las frutas muchas de
ellas provienen del extranjero buenas
noticias en todo caso para algunos
productores nacionales el tomate y la
patata que también habían vivido su gran
momento en parte gracias a las sanciones
y especialmente las contra sanciones que
cerraron el paso a algunos productos de
la unión europea
[Música]
la pandemia llegó en un momento en el
que la crisis provocada por las
sanciones económicas re impuestas por el
gobierno de donald trump se hacían mayor
y tenían mayor impacto en el país esto
hacía bastante complicado la importación
de productos extranjeros pero
especialmente la adquisición de estos
productos no locales por parte de la
población para quienes eran carísimos
especialmente porque el real la manera
local se ha evaluado más de un 50 por
ciento en los últimos meses esto se hizo
aún más difícil después de que el líder
supremo de la revolución prohibiera la
importación de todos aquellos productos
que puedan ser producidos en irán esto
con el objetivo de potencializar y
ayudar a la economía local pero tuvo un
inconveniente para los industriales y es
que tenían que importar la materia prima
desde el exterior lo que se hace aún más
complicado no porque estos productos
estén sancionados sino por las
dificultades que las sanciones traen
para hacer transferencias monetarias con
el extranjero y esto se hizo aún más
difícil para importar las medicinas lo
que ha tenido un gran impacto en la
respuesta al coi 19
[Música]
los patrones de consumo han cambiado en
costa rica a raíz de la pandemia y con
ello algunos productos de importación
han caído drásticamente de acuerdo a las
cifras del banco central el mango el
búnker y el plátano son los principales
perdedores pero en la lista también
destacan materiales como el cemento la
cal el yeso la piedra la arena y arcilla
que son menos demandados en estos meses
en que la actividad de la construcción
ha sido severamente golpeada la gasolina
y el diésel también se importan menos en
2020 si se compara con el mismo período
del año anterior
ello guardaría relación con la drástica
reducción del desplazamiento de las
personas en transporte privado debido a
las restricciones de movilidad ordenadas
por el gobierno basadas en los dígitos
de las placas de los automóviles
particulares algunos artículos
producidos en costa rica también han
visto mermadas sus ventas uno de ellos
es la cerveza la compañía productora de
cerveza nacional más grande del país
reportó que el consumo de la bebida
retrocedió 20 años sólo entre marzo y
abril al inicio del confinamiento hubo
un aumento inusual en la compra
pero luego bajo el consumo los
productores locales lo atribuyen a la
reducción de compra en oficinas ya que
por la pandemia muchos empleados ahora
laboran desde casa
[Música]